in addition to l2 regularization another
very powerful regularization technique
is called drop out let's see how that
works let's say you've trained a neural
network where the one on the left and is
overfitting just what you do with
dropout let me make a copy of the neural
network with dropout what we're going to
do is go through each of the layers of
the network and set some probability of
eliminating a node in your network so
let's say that for each of these layers
we're going to for each note of the coin
and have a 0.5 challenge of keeping each
node and 0.5 cons of removing each node
so after the coin tosses maybe you
decide to eliminate those nodes then
what you do is actually remove all the
in going outgoing links from that node
as well so you end up with a much
smaller really much diminished Network
and then you do back propagation
training this one example on this much
diminished network and then on different
example you would toss the set of coins
again and keep a different set of nodes
and they drop out eliminated different
set of nodes and so for each training
example you would train it using one of
these newer reduce networks so maybe who
seems like a slightly crazy technique to
just go go around killing those at
random but this actually works but you
can imagine that because you're training
a much smaller network on each example
maybe you know this gives a sense of why
you end up able to regularize the
network because these much smaller
networks are being trained so let's look
at how you can implement dropout there
are a few ways of implementing drop-off
I'm going to show you the most common
one which is technique called inverted
dropout for the sake of completeness
let's say we want to illustrate this
wave from layer L equals V so in the
code I'm going to write there'll be a
bunch of threes here that's just you
know that I'm just a little tree health
into and drop out in a single layer so
one thing to do is
a vector D G 3 is going to be the
dropout vector for layer 3 that's what 3
is to be MP dot random dot R and and
then is going to be the same shape as a
3 and going to see if this is less than
some number which I'm gonna call keep
problem and so cheap prop is a number it
was 0.5 on the previous slide and maybe
now I use 0.8 in this example and
there'll be the probability that a given
hidden unit will be kept
so if key problem is equal to 0.8 then
this means that there's a 0.2 chance of
eliminating any hidden unit so what this
does is it generates a random matrix um
and this works as well if you have
vectorized but so DC will be a matrix
where for each example and the each
hidden unit there's a 0.8 chance that
the corresponding DC will be 1 and the
20% chance will be 0 all right so no
this this random number being less than
0.8 there's a point a chance at being 1
or being true and at 2015 Johnson
playing to charms are being false of
being 0 and then what you're going to do
is take your activations from the 3rd
layer I'm just call it a fee in this
little example so a 3 are the
activations you compute it and I'm going
to send a 3 to be equal to the old a 3
times ok so there's an element-wise
multiplication or I guess you could also
write this as a a 3 x equals d3 but what
this does is for every element of DV
that's equal to 0 and there's a 20%
chance of each of the elements being 0
you end up this multiplier operation
ends up zeroing out the corresponding
element of DC well if you do this in
Python technically d3 will be a boolean
array what values true and false rather
than 1 and 0 but it'll multiply the
multiplier operation we're going to
interpret the true and false values as 1
and 0 if you try to just open Python you
you see then finally we're going to take
a 3 and scale it up by dividing by 0.8
or
really dividing by our cheap prop
parameter so let me explain what this
final step is doing let's say for the
sake of argument then you have 50 units
or 50 neurons in the third hidden layer
so maybe a three is fifty by one
dimensional or if your factorization
will be 50 by M dimensional so if you
have a eighty percent chance of keeping
them type is enchanted eliminating them
this means that on average you end up
with ten units you know shut off for 10
units zero and so now if you look at the
value of V 4 V 4 is going to be equal to
W 4 times a 3 plus B 4 and so on
expectation this will be reduced by 20%
by which I mean that 20% of the elements
of a 3 will be 0 L so in order to not
reduce the expected value of B 4
what you do is you need to take this and
divide it by 0.8 because this will you
know correct or just bump it back up by
the roughly 20% a unique so it's to not
change the expected value of a 3 and so
this line here is what's called the
inverted dropout technique and this
effect is that no matter what you said
the key prop to whether there's point 8
or 4 9 or even one it deserves a wonder
there's no drop out because you keeping
everything 0.5 or whatever this inverted
dropout technique by dividing by the key
prop it ensures that the expected value
of a3 remains the same and it turns out
that at test time when you're trying to
be valid in your network we stop on the
next slide this inverted dropout
technique there's this lines etc through
the green box around this makes test
time easier because you have less of a
scaling problem but by far the most
common implantation of drop-off today or
as I know is inverted dropouts I
recommend you just links mentis but
there were some very iterations of
dropout then miss this / g probe line
and so at test time the album became
involved in more complicated but but
again people tend not to use those other
versions so what you do is you use the D
vector and you notice that for different
training examples you zero out different
hidden unions and in fact if you make
multiple passes through the same
training set then on different pulses
through the training set
you should randomly zero different
hidden units so it's not that for one
example you should keep dealing of the
drift same hidden units is that on
iteration one of gradient descent you
might zero something in unions and on
the second iteration again this and we
go through the training set a second
time maybe you set zero in a different
pattern of hidden units and the vector D
or D three for the third layer is used
to decide what's a zero out both in for
prop as well as in that problem just
showing forward prop here now having
trained the algorithm at test times
here's what you would do at time you're
given some X on which you want to make a
prediction and using our standard
notation I'm going to use a zero
activations of the zero of layer to
denote this test example X so what we're
going to do is not use dropout at test
time in particular which is going to set
Z 1 equals W 1 a 0 plus B 1 a 1 equals G
1 of Z 1 Z 2 equals W 2 a 1 plus B 2 a 2
equals and so on until where you get to
the last layer in the you make a
prediction Y hat but notice that at test
time you're not using dropout explicitly
and then you're not tossing coins around
them you're not flipping coins to decide
which hidden units to eliminate and
that's because we're making predictions
there test time you don't really want
your output to be random if you were
implementing dropout at test time that
just add noise to your predictions in
theory one thing you could do is run the
prediction process many times with
different hidden units randomly
drop-down and then average across them
but that's computationally inefficient
and it gives you roughly the same result
very very similar result to this to the
procedure as well and I just mention the
inverted dropout theorem
step on a previous slide where we
divided by the cheap problem The effect
of that was ensure that even when you
don't implement dropout and test time to
the scaling the expected value of these
activations don't change so you don't
need to add in an extra funny scaling
parameter at test time that's different
than when you had a training time
so that's dropouts and when your implant
is in this week's for an exercise you
gain more first-hand experience with it
as well but why does it really work what
I want to do in the next video is give
you some better intuition about what
dropout really is doing let's go on to
the next video